if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just
[Music]
big massive
[Music]
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once dumps dumps
[Music]
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody a massive
dumps cost of the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost
the election what
is going on here what is going on right
welcome everybody yeah that song i now
play that on loop when i'm working at a
cafe
uh just really really good um sort of
like focus music i find it helps me
really focus in so i've been uh
i've been playing that okay let's get
right into it we are uh standing by
for a major announcement from oh sorry
hold on a second
already have to ban and ban hammer we
are starting
we are standing by for a major
announcement from joe biden
what it will be i have no idea but it is
happening very very soon i am wearing a
hat
people came to me they said sir it's a
bad hair day you may want to wear a hat
so i am wearing one
but i will remove it and expose what's
going on uh if we get to 100
members i'm almost hoping we don't get
there because
it's not good it's not good um okay
yesterday i participated in a chess
tournament with uh
the botez sisters it was a twitch
exclusive
and i came in about in the middle there
were 33 people i came in
i think 16th or something like that and
there were massive dumps of
anti-semitism we
i was sort of talking to the moderators
on our uh
on our discord and they uh thought that
they were
it was people trying to tilt me from the
standpoint of the chess
and it didn't work but we were just
banning them it was like playing
whack-a-mole
and as a result of this we have tons
of unban requests so i'm going to get to
those momentarily
we do have a super chat from chakuseki
who says david i tried to make a
purchase with
dogecoin doji coin dodgecoin
however you want to say it using your
illegal membership coupon but it didn't
work please advise
yeah you know i actually have been in
doge dogecoin
price i bought it as a goof
it was a complete and total goof but i
bought
dogecoin uh what was the date of that
hearing
whenever the date of the hearing was um
where the congresswoman said doji coin
that's when i bought it i think it must
have been like
was it mid-march or something like that
i don't even know
uh it was around this price or was it
early april
it was around like 17 cents yeah i've
just been holding and then i saw
it went bonkers so i sold 25
i've now locked in a profit even if the
rest goes to zero
and we'll see what happens there's these
rumors that it'll go bonkers on on
saturday when elon musk hosts snl
i don't know i really i just have no
idea i'm just holding
and that's it uh the gme mania was when
i did it yeah so that is true but it is
not currently accepted
on joinpakman.com not currently accepted
but maybe something that we will
we will look at um
sir people are calling you david hatman
it's really a big massive dump of name
calling
very strongly powerful in the direction
of hat okay
upselling memberships with a hair reveal
david hatman any ideas on holding a
viewer chess tournament soon yeah i'd
probably do it
how many siblings do you have two are
you the middle child no
no i am very powerfully the oldest
um excuse me i want to say thank you to
half cabbage
as well as guitar goddess blue moon
maiden
all who just grabbed twitch subscribe
what what the heck
how long was i gone for
how long was i gone anybody know
just a few seconds okay 30 seconds felt
like an hour yeah it felt like an hour
to me
uh unbanned requests on twitch there is
a mechanism if you get banned
where you can ask to be unbanned i will
adjudicate these
and these will be final decisions a user
named leaking tasty
showed up yesterday they created their
account
on tuesday showed up yesterday
and said hydroxychloride cures voter
fraud
hydroxychloroquine is the only effing
cure for two impeachments
use hydroxychloroquine
hydroxychloroquine cures everything
daddy
hydroxychloroquine for cancer
hydroxychloroquine 2024.
i'm really depressed and suicidal i
don't know what to do
hydroxychloroquine 2024. they were then
banned their unban
request was why am i banned for asking
for help
i'm sorry for bothering you all i've
been struggling with depression
and tourette's syndrome yeah tourette
syndrome doesn't make you
type swears that is going to be denied
and denied and if you actually need
medical attention i encourage you to
call 9-1-1 and seek that
next we had a user named holy moly
who made their account monday showed up
and said freeze in a gulag you
reactionary
s-head david pakman freeze in siberia
you reactionary lib [ __ ] [ __ ] lib
david pakman they were banned their
unban request
is you [ __ ] [ __ ] freeze in gulag that
is a
permaban adjudicated
and then lastly a user named doom
knuckle
whose account is only three days old
uh oh this i just banned them they
showed up and at the moment i went live
they said is this a libtard stream
i banned them and then they came back
with
f u f word you know the second the other
f word
that is a permaban and adjudicated
so there it is um
three appeals and uh three
denials sad in some sense but
those are the right decisions okay
thanks everybody
um all right let's continue because we
do have a lot
a lot a lot to cover today um let me
just get my material
oh and thank you to slingblade as well
as
prankish track asf clops
for the twitch subs putting us at seven
i will take the hat off uh if we get to
a hundred and expose
why i'm wearing a hat and there's a very
specific reason
um okay next uh hold on we did doji coin
do you guys want to do caitlyn jenner
interview
do you want to do wait what is this oh
do you want to do the sam cedar um
ronald reagan moment where he trolls him
related to the show
do you want to see jew versus nazi this
is very interesting
or do you want to see an interview with
a guy helping with the audit in arizona
it's like it's too much
right it's just there's it's too many
good things
um let's get okay yeah
let's get the sam cedar thing out of the
way first because it's short here we go
your humiliating loss in the race to 1
million
youtube subscribers to david pakman
i've been doing kind of a deep dive into
what's behind that kind of like when
mitt romney lost and the republicans
did an autopsy of their party uh-huh i
remember that i sure didn't like that
but for you and they followed none of it
and then trump won
exactly right so take so take with a
grain of thought what i'm about to say
but i think this might really
always always do he's basically saying
do the opposite like the republicans did
after this
morning well okay um
these are bill these have been billable
hours by the way you'll be getting the
invoice
i don't doubt that at all kind of going
on okay so
um david pakman likes to plug his
instagram
he plugs his instagram a lot so if you
head over to the instagram i think
there's two
vibes that he's giving off that could
really
help you and keep in mind i have a
a minor in communication so this like
you know
i know this is coming from uh i know not
exactly ronald reagan's best material
coming from an astute place if that's
what you're trying to say i kind of know
what it
i kind of know what i'm talking about
right um
yeah the first vibe have you ever heard
uh the phrase sex
cells sex sells i think that sounds
familiar to me
yeah david pakman's not afraid to show
off a little
leg he's got the short shorts from time
to time
i'm not aware of owning any short shorts
that's interesting
i got short shorts on i've been trying
to get you to wear a tank top for casual
friday
sun's out guns out for like three years
i even sent you a tank top
and you haven't worn it now that's on
you
but it it's not gonna hurt if once in a
while
it doesn't have to be on instagram just
on the regular show right
right maybe you don't have a shirt on at
all you know whatever
um it might be
i don't know i don't know maybe we have
to have to wait for it to be a little
warmer
in the studio probably until i could
justify that i may have to get tan a
little bit i'm a little i don't know why
we're trying to copy pack but i feel
like if sex sells sam needs to get on
only fans
or i don't know what conversation we
have i mean we might as well
go i agree you know why can't i wear the
short shorts
on instagram why do i have to wear a sun
you know
because like there's legs but really
it's the guns that that's where you
gotta
you gotta one up that's the uh i you
know strategy
people have talked about my calves in
the past and it's not been idol chatter
you
literally just said they were short all
right anyway so that's ronald reagan's
attempt at
humor uh we are standing by for uh joe
biden and we are we're going to see that
uh it's still some some period of time
away
uh so we've got that um i want to say
thanks to nikki
as well as ragulini for signing up via
twitch new members number eight and nine
remember that there is a secret
immoral but legal unpublished coupon
code
immoral 21 which you can use at
joinpakman.com i would
very strongly encourage you to take
advantage of that
we we do you know all these things we
don't have uh
yeah i know people say soros this and
that
we actually don't have anyone like soros
we have no sugar daddy for lack of a
better term
so we really do depend on people who
sign up at jointpakman.com
and i would love it if you did that and
if we get to 100 i will
take my hat off and explain why i am
wearing it
john says i want democrats to win in
2022 but i'm not confident they will
neither am i
a lot of people are getting complacent
keep in mind 911 was mostly bipartisan
covet is still highly partisan see the
difference
yes absolutely absolutely
parkman with the sox hat on go phillies
okay yeah whatever all right
let's go to let's go
next to this this is an interview with
one of the guys participating in the
audit happening in arizona it's
completely delusional take a listen to
he says that they're looking for bamboo
fibers because that would be an
indication some of the ballots came from
asia and are not legitimate ballots look
at this the other day at the press
conference you were talking about bamboo
what was that about well is that there's
accusations that 40 000
ballots were flown in to arizona into
arizona
and it was stuffed into the box okay and
it came from
the southeast part of the world asia
okay
and uh and what they're doing is to find
out
if there's bamboo in the paper that
camera right there that they take a
picture of the ballot
if you they can really look at depth
and find out is it a handmark paper
ballot right
it's a 5k camera you can see the folds
in the ballot because 92
of all the ballots here should have been
folded this is making a lot of sense
actually
because they came in through an envelope
okay and so they're doing all sorts of
testing to prove
if it was or wasn't and that's very
important because the only way you can
persuade people
on changing is having facts and we're on
a mission for facts
i would actually check if any of the
ballots have raccoon prints because i
believe that the the conspiracy
is actually raccoon handlers are the
ones
harvesting ballots and so if there's any
uh raccoon prince
on any on the envelope and that's why
you have to keep the envelope remember
they're throwing the envelope out
getting rid of the
raccoon prince you really have to keep
it's not just bamboo we need to be
looking for
elections usa and what we do is not
about the right or left
audit is an acronym it stands for
americans united for democracy integrity
and transparency
we've been around 17 years so anyway
he's keeping an eye out for bamboo
fibers on the ballots because that would
be
strongly indicative of something
something
um by the way what does a ketchup stain
on the ballot tell you what what would
that signal
a big thank you to charles cole charles
just went to join pacman.com and got a
membership and now has access
to the award-winning bonus show also
want to say thank you to
the bedizzle who just grabbed a twitch
sub
as well as a danish joint new members
11 and 12 today and here is joe biden
let's listen
well mr mayor governor
thank you uh it's good to be back in
lake charles
it's a pleasure been here a number of
times over the years
as senator and then as vice president
first time i came down here biden's
wearing the sunglasses so he will almost
certainly be dropping the hammer on
someone
was a guy named russell long who i
served with i was
29 please sit down everybody
i was 29 years old when i got elected
and i uh went to see russell long
sit the hell down and he said son i made
my
stops to all the senior senators which
is what you do in those days
and he said son sit down sit down
pound us in his desk and i sat down he
said
he said how much money did you spend in
your campaign
and i said well sir and this is going to
shock you
i said uh i said sir i said a little
over 285 thousand dollars but then i had
to borrow some money
uh and to get through it and i just won
barely by
let's let's a half a percentage point
and he said well he said good thing you
won
and i said how's that he said well he
said
you got yourself a 38 000 deficit
and i said yes sir he said well if you
had one you just have a plain old
deficit
now you can have a deficit party
whoa god i miss he was amazing that's
edgy amazing guy
and both of you are amazing mr mayor
you've got a great city
and uh as i said i've been here uh i've
been here more than once and uh
and it's good to be back and i i it's
hard to believe that uh
that you got uh you got hit as badly as
you have
within the time what is happening and uh
i used to spend some time with randy he
got hit a little bit but not like you
did
not like you have and gov uh you know we
have to build back
we have to build back better one of the
things that
that i'm proud of is in the first 100
days
that i became president we have
created more jobs in that period of time
than any administration in history but
the way i look at that that's just the
down payment getting us back for the
american recovery act
just getting us back and getting people
a lot of that had to do with getting
people vaccinated
getting 600 million doses of of the uh
of a vaccine and getting people
in a position where it was available but
now it's about
rebuilding america right rebuilding in a
way that
it has resilience and the folks are
going to rebuild are those folks right
over there
unions we're going to rebuild it in a
way that we're going to provide good
jobs
well look uh it's as i said it's good to
be back governor edwards and
mayor hunter and i also want to thank
president wren union president afl-cio
head of the
head of the uh the there you are i
couldn't find you
um not super strong energy today uh um
there's uh when it comes to bridges and
roads
and i like i've never seen a republican
or democrat road
uh i just see roads and uh mary
you're a republican you wrote a
newspaper article suggesting that
that we along with the governor
the democratic mayor of shreveport mayor
perkins
as to why we need the american jobs plan
and
which is what i'm here to talk about
today okay a once-in-a-generation
investment
in american america itself great jobs to
modernize our
our bridges our roads our highways our
porch
our airports our water pipes our water
projects high-speed internet
transmission lines and sustainable
housing
sustainable housing jobs rebuilding the
foundations of a strong
fair and resilient resilient competitive
economy
you know i know the times have been
tough here the damage of the hurricanes
have been devastating
governor's already spoken to me we're
talking with omb and with our
folks and republicans and democrats in
the congress because i believe
i believe you need to help i believe you
need the help we're going to try to make
sure you get it
but people louisiana always pick
themselves up just like
just like america always picks itself up
there's no uh
there's no quit in america there's no
quit in louisiana that i've observed
but that doesn't mean the federal
government uh because it was uh local
doesn't mean it shouldn't help i promise
you we're gonna build back better never
more resilient
and and build back in a way that all we
build is
better able to withstand storms and that
are becoming more severe
and more frequent than ever i think we
have to you might have noticed i
promised i would have a
a uh i would have a climate form
for the world in washington within 100
days
well 40 heads of state showed up from
the largest countries in the world to
some of the smallest
right you can't deny it there is a real
change in the in the weather and if we
go
1.5 degrees warmer we're going to be in
real trouble a point of no return
matter of fact a lot of we're going to
have to build back now in terms of
infrastructure
we've got to build back to a different
standard not to what it was
it's got to be better because the
climate has changed enough now
that it's still going to rise two feet
when it rains still going
we got to build for what is needed now
when it rains i promise you
we're going to do that that i don't
understand better so we're better
prepared to withstand
storms and becoming more severe more
frequent
we're standing here in the shadow of the
i-10 bridge
which i've gone over several times
myself in the past
and it's a perfect example how we've
neglected as a nation to invest in the
future of our economy
and the future of our people you know
when the bridge was built in 1952
it was built to there's nothing there
the storm surge will go higher okay that
we in fact are able to it was going to
last for 50 years
that was 20 years ago it was built for
50 years
the i-10 bridge was built to handle
daily traffic load of 37 000 crossings
well but today every day more than
eighty thousand
more than eighty thousand cars and
trucks cross over that bridge
and it doesn't have the modern safety
features that bridges need to have now
you know six lanes of interstate narrow
into four lanes of a bridge
that's a that's a a recipe for disaster
and that's what i'm sure you don't need
to tell the drivers around lake charles
that it means trapping bottlenecks and
delays and
and at the last inspection this bridge
was categorized as in poor condition
and after decades a politician studying
it and
talking about it governor edwards is one
finally moving forward
with a project to actually replace the
bridge
one with six lanes new interchanges
that's safer
reduces congestion and it shouldn't be
as hard it shouldn't be this hard to
take
or take so long extremely wet from the
standpoint of
water sense but the truth is across the
country
we have failed we have failed to
properly invest in infrastructure for
half a century
last four years how many times you say
this is going to be
infrastructure weak well i got so tired
hearing infrastructure week
nothing nothing happened that's true
nothing has happened
and across america there are more than
45 hear me now
45 000 bridges that are structurally
deficient
structurally deficient every day
americans cross
would you believe joe is up to his knees
in water
right now at times and they are
structurally deficient
we've seen what happens when they
deteriorate remember a few years ago
two counties over in mississippi had to
shut down
more than 60 bridges that were in poor
condition 60 bridges
people in those communities were
rerouted from 40 to 50 miles detours
with half hour to hour delays one of the
areas when i was doing this with our
last major plan that when barack was
president
was in pennsylvania there was a large
shopping center
school and the rest and it was just
across the creek as we say
up in that that way and uh and the
bridge across it was deficient
but there was a fire station just to an
eyesight from here to
to the others to that the parking lot
but guess what
when there was a burn when there was a
fire it took them they had to go up
nine miles to find the bridge come back
and by that time a hell of a lot of
damage was done
right well the bridges all over america
big and small
like that a few years ago as i said
we found ourselves in a position where
it's not not just more con
more inconvenient and like the in the
situation in mississippi
it is also a matter of life and death
keeping
firefighters paramedics from getting
people the help they need
cutting off hurricane evacuation routes
in addition
more than one in five miles of our
highways in the united states america
major roads in america are in poor
condition
one in five miles that's more than a
safety hazard
that is a drain on our economy typical
american pays
i know this is going to sound wonky but
it's real and it affects ordinary
americans lives like the neighborhoods i
come from
typical american pays a hidden tax on
more than one thousand dollars a year
in the time and waste and the fuel
wasted due to traffic congestion because
of the nature of our infrastructure
right we rank eighth in the world in
terms of our infrastructure
we used to be the leader in the world
all told these delays cost our country
according to economists an estimated 160
billion dollars a year in waste extra
fuel extra time and light
and that's due to the congestion and
folks louisiana
louisiana know there are much greater
threats than just congestion
when the road or the bridge is washed
out or when it can't stand up to a
hurricane
people can't get to their jobs they
can't get to the schools families can't
get the hospital safely
this is about creating jobs and also
saving lives
you know my mother used to have an
expression gov she said out of
everything bad joey something good will
come if you look hard enough
for it well one of the things that this
this crisis in terms of the health
crisis of covert has shown us
is that uh that we have to we have to
build back better in a whole
series of ways i mean hopefully we also
get rapid advancement as
uh because of the mrna technology that
would be a great thing
hurricanes and global warming and and
the
and the poor condition of our economy as
it relates particularly to
infrastructure
i think one thing i think of jobs jobs
jobs everything we're we're gone through
is now the so sort of the blinders have
been taken off the american people
they know how bad a shape things are in
but it creates if we move all the
economists including the
liberal as well as conservative think
tanks point out who will create up we
pass this jobs plan and
create up to 16 million good paying jobs
not eight dollars an hour twelve dollars
not fifteen dollars not prevailing wage
jobs
wages you can raise the family on
whenever my dad would say
just a little bit of breathing room
after everything's paid
and so you know you're this state is
working to rebuild the i-10 bridge but
we can
put america to work in every state
fixing roads and bridges that are in
desperate need of repair
my plan is a one-time 115
billion dollar investment above and
beyond business as usual
we usually do everything in the highway
trust fund this is above what we have
spent in the past
so we can modernize bridges and roads
and highways that need it most
putting people to work and good paying
jobs now i know a lot of you watching at
home
are thinking that well you know if these
jobs are for you
well you know all the folks who feel
left out is economy
movement so rapidly everything's
changing and you're wondering whether
what you did before or is he going to be
available to be done in the future well
let me tell you something
if you feel left out and forgotten in a
rapidly changing economy let me speak
directly to you nearly 90
of all the infrastructure jobs that this
is going to create
won't require a college degree 75
percent of women
require an associate's degree these are
jobs that can't be outsourced
can't be outsourced they just require
something
we've got in good supply here in
louisiana
in louisiana hard work grit and sweat
like the workers that are here today and
like all of the people you know and grew
up with
american jobs plan is a blue collar
blueprint
to rebuild america a blue-collar
blueprint
to rebuild america to supercharge our
economy
so we can move goods get to work become
more competitive around the world
you know to shorten our commutes to give
us back a lost time to our families to
make
our commute savers save lives all told
the american jobs plan
is going to modernize 20 000 miles of
highways and roads it will fix the
nation's 10 most economically
significant bridges that require
replacement they're just not safe
anymore
which this bridge could be one of them
it repairs
10 000 bridges that desperately need to
be upgraded
bridges it gets kids to school people to
market and you know
when you build better roads or extend
the train line over the next town or
install
reliable high-speed internet it sparks
new life and investment in communities
it gives people hope business picks up
at the local convenience store
i'm not joking i actually am unsure what
the announcement is there was an
announcement teased but i'm not sure
what it is
and their jobs and their economies
better jobs
start coming to town you haven't seen
that in a long time
suddenly young people don't have to make
the decision whether they have to leave
to have a better opportunity
they stay where they are that's what
infrastructure does there's a rippling
effect
and when it makes all of we make all
these investments we're going to make
sure
one thing that we buy american
now i know i'm being accused that i say
i'm only going to buy american as
president
that somehow i'm going to violate trade
agreements no
since the 1930s you're allowed the
president could just decide
to buy only american it's not it's just
i'm going to get to spend somewhere in
the order of 600 billion dollars this
year
everything from building an aircraft
carrier new decks and all
and i guarantee you one thing and i've
set it in place
every single thing from the deck of an
aircraft carrier to a railing in the new
building
is going to be built by an american
company
american workers american supply chain
so that we invest american tax dollars
in american workers and that's we're
going to do
i promise you because right now that law
has existed but you're allowed to have
exceptions
so what do you do last president's come
along and said
well we have a little trouble making
sure we can find somebody who
is able to put the railings in this new
building and the stairwells
well guess what there's a whole hell of
a lot of americans to make that so we're
going to have
a spot you just call the white house
we'll find you any company that makes
those railings for example it's one
concrete example
rather than going abroad concrete i like
that it's going to create
jobs i'm going to generate a concrete
example that you guys get
this is all about making a choice a
choice between giving tax breaks to
super wealthy and to corporations and
investing in working families
we're going to build a country i look at
this as
what i'm talking about has given
essentially tax breaks
to hard-working middle-class and working
people who built this country in my view
it's an easy choice investing in workers
wearing hard hats and doing the hard
work of rebuilding the country and put
line workers
for example to put line workers and
electricians to work laying thousands of
miles of transmission lines
to build a modern energy grid to put
engineers and construction workers to
work building modern roads and bridges
weatherizing homes and buildings and
setting new standards where they have to
be built
with better material and they have to be
built to withstand heavy winds and
hurricanes and the like
and withstand the impact of of the
changing weather
to put plumbers and pipefitters to work
replacing 100
of the nation's lead pipes and service
lines that are delivering
poison water to our kids and over 400
000 400 000 schools
in america have lead pipes leading to i
mean 400 000
uh uh yes that's right 400 000 have lead
pipes
going to the schools right now and you
have
over 10 million homes where their water
sources fed by
lead pipes were laid years and years ago
we're going to rip it all up
all up and make it rip it up all across
america tear it down
it's going to provide millions of jobs
thousands of jobs and it's going to
provide
much more security it's going to put
plumbers and pipefitters to work
you know tearing down and rebuilding
stuff would generate a lot of jobs you
need the people to do it the first thing
and then you build it back and then you
end up with the same thing you start
with of course that's not what he's
proposing but that is a way to create
jobs
to modernize the city's water system
because it needs modernization
and they need to repair look these are
the highest values investments you can
make as a nation
and they last the longest economist left
right and center
agree that these are investments we need
to make to generate historic economic
growth that's
maintained maintained not just bringing
jobs back but creating
new jobs and together with the american
rescue plan the american jobs plan is
going to help the economy
yeah i don't want to give politicians
any ideas over 16 million good paying
jobs and folks
we can't afford to not do it
we can't afford to not spend the time
and effort of money
let me explain how we pay for this
because i'm not a deficit spender
because you know we had a tax cut the
other team put in
back in 19 2017 and it created
two trillion yeah this is a fair point
via super chat republicans are depending
on the people drinking leaded water and
eating paint chips to be voting for them
and thus if
you solve that problem what happens to
those voters pay your fair share just
pay
for example if we just were to make sure
that
we had the tax rate for the top rate in
america
for income tax what it was in the bush
administration
it would go from 36 to 39.6 percent
well guess what that that that would
raise a minimum of 10 billion dollars a
year
no one's hurt someone making that money
is still going to have two homes or
a jet plane or these are mostly
millionaires they're not going to be
hurt a little bit
but we're going to be able to put tens
of thousands of kids
in preschool and in
free community college what's going to
help america more
increase the educational standard of all
americans
so they have 14 years of school
from two years of three and
five-year-olds
three four and five years old we show
that that happens if they get not go to
daycare
they go to school no matter what the
background of the home they come from
they catch up
58 percent will go on to go to college
we know that now
we also know that if you give two years
two years of free community college
you're in a situation where you're in a
position that
you have in your state and every other
state in america
you'll allow to go the last two years
there all those credits are available to
your state universities you get a
four-year degree for half the cost
and or you get the two-year degree and
you're able to do what you needed to do
it's estimated to increase the average
income by over 20 percent for someone
in america for the rest of their lives
so folks
you know the fact is that i'm saying i'm
not looking to punish anyone
you know i come from the corporate state
of the world
delaware more corporations are
incorporating the state of delaware than
every other state in the union country
they're not actually based there but yes
you know i'm sick and tired of corporate
america not paying their fair
share their taxes used to be
38 36 percent we all thought that was
too high even in our administration
and we wanted to reduce it to 28 make it
more competitive
some thought 24 but it got reduced to 21
and you know what the result is of the
largest corporation in america 50 don't
pay a penny in tax
made 40 billion don't pay a penny in tax
if you're a construction worker and your
wife's a school teacher
you're paying at a higher tax rate than
corporate america's pain not a joke
not a joke i don't want to punish them
and by the way they used to do a lot
more research and development
major corporations now because we
changed the law
in fact it used to be the corporate ceo
got paid 36 times as much as the average
employee in their corporation the
fortune 500. now it's 456 times
right the mother would say who died and
left them boss
well 56 of all
the 53 percent of all the money they
made excuse me
of a trillion dollars over 10 years what
did it do according to a major study
it went to buying back their stock and
why you buy back their stock
because ceos now get paid in stock
purchases
stock options it used to be they got
paid in direct salary
and they get paid in stock options so if
you have 10 shares of stock you sell
five the five left are worth more you
pay
this is not a particularly linear speech
i i
agree with people in the chat yeah
believes nine percent
nine percent for everything according to
the study at the university of
massachusetts
everything from salaries
employment research development nine
percent
so folks you know we used to invest
there's a lot of great substance here
there's no doubt
about 2.4 of all all that we did
have making us a leading country in the
world and change in research and
development
when we now do 0.7 the chinese are
eating our lunch
eating our lunch economically they're
investing
hundreds of billions of dollars in
research and development
that's why right now if it keeps going
away they're going to own the electric
car market in the world
they're going to own a whole range we
got to compete we got to compete
and it doesn't cost anybody anything and
deprive anybody of anything they
have earned or deserve as i said
we're now at a place where when they
used to pay 35
it's now 21. the way i can pay for this
is the 40 billion dollars for example
just making sure the largest companies
don't pay zero
right and reducing i mean to be clear i
prefer his tangents to trump sunny day
at least they're relevant
five and 28 it's a couple hundred
billion dollars we can pay for these
things
i'm not talking about deficit spending
i'm talking about paying for i won't go
i realize i'm getting too wonky share
giving you too much detail
but the point is oh man what i'm
proposing
is badly needed and able to be paid for
and still
grow trickle down ain't working very
well man
right we got a bill from the bottom and
up in the middle out
that's how we build america that's how
we built it so well back in the 60s
and so folks look middle flax family as
i said in a construction worker
uh with a kid with two kids is paying
more in federal taxes than a
multi-million dollar
billion-dollar uh corporation that's
making billions of dollars
in terms of the rate which they pay
and look here we go you know still the
fact is that
the plans that i put forward meets the
middle class and raises corporate rate
it also
lowers it where lower than any point
that it was
since world war ii and it's going to
generate
90 billion dollars each year hundreds of
thousands of jobs we're going to put a
lot of folks to work
and by the way how many of you are
veterans uh or no or
have a brother sister mother father as a
veteran
right well here in lake charles you've
got a new veterans clinic it was built
a few years ago beginning when barack
and i were in office
but most va hospitals for example are 50
years old or older
ask your buddies ask your buddies
when they we have more people more
veterans and more active military
committing suicide
every week than are killed in all our
wars
why pick up a volume we have more people
coming back with post-traumatic stress
than anything else i carry in my pocket
my schedule
the back of my schedule i have updates
u.s troop updates how many people have
died
in iraq and afghanistan not generally
over six thousand six thousand
as of this morning 927.
every single solitary one of those
fallen angels
left an entire community behind wounded
53 196 not roughly 53
000. well guess what ask your people
ask around in your state in any other
state you got a
husband a wife calling saying she's
having she
she has post-traumatic stress and she's
i need to get her in there right away
but we can't see you for three weeks we
don't have enough docks
and the buildings are 15 years old i
mean the truth is a three-week wait
isn't that uncommon
in any you know even anywhere in the u.s
i mean
specialists etc it's not specific to the
vet system
psychiatric nurses in order to take care
of these things
look folks the bottom line here is i'm
going on too long the american jobs plan
puts people to work
upgrading va hospitals and put for our
veterans and our service members
military
families and let me ask you what's
better for america
a tax cut to make corporations richer
and ceos
richer our investment is going to make
our country stronger more competitive
and lift up the standard learning for
everybody and by the way this is not
punishing anybody all those folks are
still going to have two homes or three
homes in their jets it
won't matter perfect not going to change
their standard in one
little bit not surprisingly critics say
they worry that i'm going to
stunt economic growth by raising taxes
on corporations the wealth there's just
one problem with their argument
the facts experts have looked at it
the last time taxes were around the
rates i'm proposing was in the 90s
and the economy boomed unique.com
situation it was a bubble
i don't know i'm not sure about that
american economy has had a record job
creation and growth
under the same kind of plan i'm
proposing and here's why our economy has
always done best when everyone pays
their fair share
again i'm looking to punish anybody i'm
looking to rebuild america as a world
leader
i'm going to look to make sure we have
the best and most significant
infrastructure in the world it's time to
grow this economy
from the bottom up and the middle out
let me close with this
infrastructure has historically been a
bipartisan undertaking
there's no reason it shouldn't be that
way again as there is evidence of and
others are
it's about coming together to create
jobs to make more competitive world
what's the first thing anybody ask you
when they want to put
a new facility here in your city
how close is the interstate how you know
what's the access to
the lake what's going i mean what's the
water supply
they want to know you have the best
infrastructure companies and
corporations go where they can get their
product made the quickest
and get it to market the fastest and
we're doing everything we can to win the
competition for the 21st century
i'm willing to hear ideas from both
sides i'm meeting with my republican
friends up in the
up in the congress to see number one how
much they're willing to go for
what they think of their priorities and
what compromises meet men i'm ready to
compromise
what i'm not ready to do i'm not ready
to do nothing
i'm not ready to have another period
where america has another
infrastructure month and doesn't change
the damn thing
right america is more competitive
better and more capable now we're
talking there's not a damn
thing we cannot do when we do it
together
it's about time we start working
together like mayors and local officials
do
like governors do i find more support
from republican governors and mayors
and democratic governors and mayors
around the country because they gotta
they gotta answer the question
is life better in this town this city
this state than it was before i got
elected
and we can make it better we can make it
better
it shouldn't be controversial right so
let me conclude by saying god bless you
all
and may god protect our troops thank you
there it is
and off goes joe biden
[Music]
okay um all right yeah
that was fake guys that was fake okay i
i have still more things to get to and
they may even be as interesting as what
we just saw
i do want to say thank you to diana
hutchins all right everybody relax
everybody relax
christina gurchenov and stacy smith all
of whom just signed up at
joinedpakman.com new members 16 17 and
18.
okay let's get right into jew versus
nazi this
came across my desk yesterday um i want
to be really clear
i don't know who either of these people
are i don't know what political
movements these people are associated
with i know
nothing other than this conversation is
interesting okay
let's listen this is i guess this guy's
a white nationalist that's the
impression i got from watching this
let's watch a little bit of it together
should we have brown eyed people race
and blue-eyed people race so i don't
believe in the concept of race well why
is it that white nations are the only
people that like have to be
like totally taught this nonsense what
do you mean white nations why are white
nations the only nations that have to
bow take a knee
and basically give up our our identity
and our our customs our way of life
because of what
you're talking about because of some
fake event that happened in world war
ii so you don't think the holocaust
happened well i mean
i don't believe that there were death
camps like when i was a child
have you been to poland into auschwitz
oh that's that's good i know you guys
like to ask them no
yeah because when you experience it
firsthand
and you see first of all half of my
family was exterminating the holocaust
plenty of jews that have been there
yeah that are intellectuals that you
know
are on our side that laugh at your what
is what is your side what is your
goal yeah i when a guy like this starts
talking about our side
the the perfect question is what exactly
is your side
represent i'd love to uh well i'm a i'm
a i'm i'm not an intellectual i'm not
educated right that's fine but i'm i'm
this new
breed of humans that like grew up
this guy's a new breed the information
age
and um so this this post-war propaganda
is wearing off and we're able to like
check
you know all these publications and you
know that you've printed over
you've printed i'm one person well you
the jews oh come on guy dude
are you do you represent the jewish
people no i think every individual
represents themselves
i represent the white race
oh wow this is this is just something
what is the right right
wait wait wait wait wait for the whole
entire white race okay can you tell me
first what that means i'd love
before european descent okay germanic
swedish nordic celtic
we are the true israelites you are
imposters so can you explain that to me
yes it's very simple yes we are pure
blooded
you are mixed monger this guy is a real
this this is the real is if this is the
real israelite we're in trouble
trolls yeah you're a mongrel race okay
based on what information it's it's all
we have to do is look at you
oh so you look at me it's weird because
if you just put these two people in
front of me and say david do something
extremely superficial
judge books by their covers look at
these two
and just look at don't listen to what
they're saying but just look at them
look at their tone demeanor i just lost
my earpiece
just just make an evaluation simply on
optics
i don't know that i'm saying the guy on
the right is the picture of what i
should be
uh um looking for right i don't know
that this guy
really should be asking for judgments to
be made based on what they look like
i'm talking about your race well hold up
i'm not sure
the jews right so let's let's have let's
have a calm conversation
and i have some questions for you
because i'm really interested in
engaging with you but
for real we need to okay i appreciate it
so so i want to understand
where the ideology and you you tell me
because this is your beliefs
how the white nation as you say european
descents
are the people of israel where's the
where's the link between
coming from israel and we being into
slavery in egypt and then coming back to
israel then
where where's the like continuation how
did it end up being the this guy's going
to explain how he's the true israelite
descendants understand my question
yes adam and eve were the first white
people
white humans how do we know that because
they were pure blooded white in
uh
oh god wow
this is this is one of the best videos
i've seen no adam
means uh ground the word in hebrew is
adama which means ground
so actually if anything the ground would
be more brown than white
now you think jesus had brown eyes like
i don't know what eyes or what he looks
like
i don't know what kind of eyes like me
how do you know that
this is in my dna and your nose
a picture of jesus is coded into this
guy's dna
because it's in your dna that means you
know how jesus looked like he carried
christians wait wait i think you're
logical you're a logical person
are you saying that the europeans don't
know their own here
i'm saying that you're a logical person
but explain to me how you know
that jesus and i'm not saying he didn't
it could have very well had blue eyes
because there's thousands of prophecies
in the scriptures that can only could
you show me one
what scriptures new and old testament
there's no mention in the original torah
the old testament saying how jesus in
fact jesus is not mentioned once
he's got to put the sunglasses back on
now
listen so i don't know what i'm saying i
i appreciate what you say and i've heard
your point of view before on the
internet sure but
this isn't agree to disagree that's fine
you sort by
conversation on behalf of all europeans
and all americans
whether they like it or not i speak on
behalf of the entire white race
when i tell you this is better than my
this is better than my richard spencer
interview
this is i've not i've never seen
anything like this
i want you and your people out of all
white nations
now and so where do we don't want you
where do we go now that's not our
problem anyway
we said not to scream at you no i'm done
with that okay
he's not he's now in the screaming
portion of the interview the
non-screaming part is con concluded
but where are you okay so and you're we
want you out of all europe
we want you out of all america you
stabbed us in the world where did the
jews go
and you've lied where did the
but explain to me where do the jews go
after nobody cares nobody likes you
no but you said that that's why you
don't have to create laws
to stop normal people from hating is
that like an allusion to
to jews control the legal system is that
what he means by you have to create laws
or is he talking about israel somehow
the jews create you guys are always
signing these anti-semitism laws because
there are people like you that exist
yeah it's called there's been there's
been there's no greater evidence
that uh whatever this guy's talking
about is needed i don't even know what
he's talking about than this guy
no i'm not totally i'm not against your
friends or european christian american
i'm not because you killed our lord and
savior and you laugh about
oh wow this is uh
wow this is called jew versus nazi part
two
i guess this guy is rudy rockman uh i
don't know anything about either of
these people i'm i'm just taking in the
content
reality is that we're both in front of
each other right and we have the ability
to use it i just don't
hold up we have the ability to use this
opportunity okay you can actually engage
with one another work on some people i'm
not using
i've already gaged you a long time ago
that's fine you know who i am no i've
never
you know who jesus was uh you're saying
you're jesus
i'm saying i am a descendant of jesus
you don't know anything
yes i okay so i don't know anything when
two seconds ago you said that jesus was
in the old testament his own stance
you just said that jesus was all right
so it's pretty wild let's skip ahead a
little just to see what else what else
happens
then we'll get away from this let me i
don't
i don't think i think of you as a as a
as a
enemy why do you hate me so much because
you killed my lord and said i didn't do
anything did 9 11.
you don't know after 19 years oh that's
not
that's as a jew that's just not
something i'm here i'm 26.
it's been a 911 i have no i didn't say
i'm not interested in 9 11.
you know you're making a claim and i'm
asking you what happened in 9 11 that
you're claiming i got to talk all day
about 9 11. okay so let me know what i'm
just asking you what's your name
that's a jewish brian grossman we need
you to get out of our country
okay like i i was not brought up to hate
jews
no he came up with that all on his own i
had friends that were jewish and believe
me i watched schindler listen
i watched schindler's list with my
family on if i didn't know any better
i'd say it was staged
i really would and by the way grossman
that i know i know
i know two people last name gross and
one named grossman they're all jewish
that's just another weird wrinkle on nbc
back in the 90s
commercial free i've never seen a movie
ever
on network television that's commercial
free that's because of the jews
everything that is claimed to be
commercial free
and then they drop in product placement
he's convinced
that's because of the jews but we
watched that and that left
such an impact and then i watched life
in beautiful and i cried
and when roberto benini won the academy
award i was so moved when he walked over
the seats and
got his academy award and now i look at
the guy on the left
he's he looks like tucker carlson during
every segment that tucker does
the guy on the left now roberto benini
guy on the left is now
what what am i doing here no it's all
jewish filth and propaganda
and you toyed with my emotions and you
toy with the american people
and you you committed genocide against
the german people
that was a beautiful beautiful culture
with the help of my grandfather because
you've drawn a line in the sand
against truth in jesus christ all right
anyway so we're done we're done with
that that's that's
it so that's um that's that's just nuts
that guy should do a dna test yeah it
would be funny if he's if he's fully
jewish
um okay let's see here
let's go oh i do want to say thank you
to max goldrich who is a new member at
jointpakman.com new member number 19.
also thanks to billy b photo fitter
and um oh that's it new members number
20 and 21
and um no i didn't miss anybody on the
website somebody said they signed up on
the website and i missed you no
i don't know what the the only website
i'm looking at is joinedpakman.com
if you signed up on some other website i
certainly did not
that's not that's not my website okay
all right
let's get into the caitlyn jenner
interview
i have a full video clip coming out
about this a little bit later
but um just to preview a little bit of
it caitlyn jenner is running for
governor of california
i guess and was interviewed by sean
hannity yesterday
and launching the interview with the
completely relatable
complaint that uh caitlyn's
private plane hanger buddy is thinking
about leaving the country
thinking about so that's i mean who we
have to we must are living
leaving california sorry leaving the
state we must consider the priorities
of the private plane owners take a look
at this california
my friends are leaving california i
actually worked my hangar the guy across
front of redmond he was packing up his
hangars where are you going
and he says i'm moving to sedona arizona
i can't take it here
anymore i can't walk down the streets
and see the homeless right
i don't want to leave okay either i
stay and fight or i get out of here
guys if you don't elect caitlyn jenner
to replace gavin newsom
uh caitlyn and her private plane owning
buddy
these uh private plane owners are going
to
take their private planes and they're
going to fly somewhere else because they
had to see homeless people on the way to
their hangar
now here's so this this could have been
interesting
you have a trans candidate who's a
republican
who is going to be asked about her
position on trans girls in sports
this had the opportunity to actually
enlighten us in some way about
here is a republican trans person
sean hannity asks about trans girls in
sports
the answer is unintelligible i couldn't
i i listened to this now this is the
fifth time i'm going to listen to it
with you
i couldn't tell you what caitlyn's
position is on trans girls in sports
tell me if you can figure it out
but girls transgender sports people that
like joy that say the wrong thing
joy that says you know i mentioned a
second ago my mom sometimes
you know when she gets upset you know
she i i don't have a problem with that
the community
has a bigger problem with that than i do
right i stick with my statements that i
made
um i think um we have to make sure
that the integrity of girls sports is
there
i think that's extremely important um
but it's there's more to it than just
what i said
because i just said biological boys in
sports
there's more to it than that and i think
in the future i will explain
more of that not tonight and me as a
a trans woman
when i figure out some way to be a
republican
and run successfully but tell you the
truth about
what i think when i figure out what that
would be i will tell you
i think role models are extremely
important for young people
trans issues people struggle with big
time our suicide rate is nine times
higher than the general public true
and um for me to be a role model for
them
uh to be out there i am running
for governor of the state of california
yeah but it's like be how okay so
you want to be a role model for trans
girls who are athletes
so like you you want to be a role model
by
participating with women or like it's
it's just it's completely opaque there's
no
i would have ever thunk that we've never
even had
a woman uh
governor but some are mad at you that's
i that's i don't you know i i move on
i want to be a role model and i think
the and to be a leader
and i think the most important thing as
a leader
that you can do is your compassion yeah
really strange it just nothing was being
answered
um okay so she says forest management is
important which is like it just sounds
like trump i'm gonna skip that one
uh here's one where caitlyn suggests
that that her statements about covid
restrictions
are why california's opening on july
15th
would you open the state of california
completely tomorrow
absolutely open it right up actually you
know what it's
just don't close in and out burger
before i leave it's even on a small
scale kind of working already
about three weeks ago uh-oh uh it was
rumored
and rightfully so it was rumored that i
was looking in to run for governor
and here we are the next day
gavin newsom has a press conference that
says the state is opening up july 15th
i'm laying there in bed and watching
this and i'm saying yes
it's already working okay so there it is
gavin newsom getting the memo clearly
and uh doing what
almost every other state is doing newsom
did it
because he heard caitlyn jenner suggest
that the state be
opened up um here caitlyn
i guess miss speaks and says that she's
for illegal immigration
and sean hannity tries to fix it and
welcome
to the announcement for the national
park service
national underground railroad oh my god
okay i don't know where that came from
so in this one sean hannity tries to
help caitlyn jenner by saying you meant
you're for legal right and then caitlyn
thanks
sean for watching out for her and
hannity just looks so uncomfortable
um yeah oh by the way he's blaming he's
blaming this recall on
cueing on anti-vaxxers and
anti-immigration
uh citizens yeah i'm pro-illegal
immigration i i i i wanted to organize
we really have to pro-legal immigration
what's that you're pro-legal legal
immigration
yes we're legal immigration sorry did i
miss the legal part
yeah thanks for catching me mm-hmm yeah
you got my back sean i appreciate that
oh i don't know i knew what you were
saying yeah
all right we'll take a break we'll come
back with caitlyn jenner running for the
governorship of the state of california
oh god it's too good
it's just it's too too good um
hannity's discomfort is what really
makes this
uh all right now um
this one i'm gonna skip for now okay now
caitlyn jenner is asked um
can you evaluate trump versus biden and
harris
like who's doing and the talking points
are
it's just completely trumpian it's
completely trumpian and like oh trump
trump was different
we've had four years of donald trump we
have joe biden and kamala harris
give me your assessment of those three
people
yes um
what i liked about donald trump as he
was a disrupter
you know that's that vap i mean that you
know you go to a random
um trump rally
and you just ask them what is it about
trump you like and they go well he's
different he's not a politician he was a
disruptor he just did things in a
different way
he came in and shook the system up
right okay a lot of people didn't like
that in
washington dc but he came in and shook
the system up
right i think he did some things that i
agreed with
some things i didn't agree with i i
you're critical on transgender issues
on trans issues lgbt issues i was more
hopeful at the beginning
um and but there was that sounds like a
plane that must be caitlyn's plane
coming to pick her up actually some good
things he did
uh on the other hand biden i don't think
i've agreed with anything i don't think
since he's been in there he has really
not even the trans stuff that you just
said you didn't agree with
i didn't agree with biden on anything
what about the trans stuff you just said
trump was a disaster on
done anything for the american worker
maybe other ones so
um it is a it is a 180 degree turn in
our country
yeah uh going the other direction and
and
uh it scares me
um super scary and then um
okay and then this is the wrap and then
caitlyn offers hannity
a ride i guess on her private plane and
now hannity looks really humiliated
caitlyn jenner thank you for being with
us it was my pleasure always a pleasure
to talk to you
good to see you again now we're gonna go
find my plane around the corner i'm
gonna take you for a flight
i'm going right his wheels up any minute
all right all right
uh thank you for the time uh we do wish
you nothing but the best we're gonna
follow this race closely
it's like hannity doesn't even know what
to wish right he doesn't he doesn't know
like we i how do i end this is there a
protocol i'm not really sure how to
handle this conversation
bizarre bizarre interview and
just really something else what i
couldn't figure out though
and maybe people in the chat have
figured it out
um what is the why is caitlyn jenner
runner for running for governor like i
don't
i don't even what was there was no case
made i've now watched this interview
multiple times in preparation for the
segment i recorded
um i couldn't understand like why why
would anyone vote for her why is she
even running i don't even understand
like even if you don't like gavin newsom
it's not
clear to me why why i just don't i don't
get it
um and von tuck's right on cue how can
we be optimistic about good done under
biden if democrats don't fight voter
suppression efforts in states they won't
win
again ever won't the republicans undo
all the good with our democracy in 2024
well that's part of this stuff you know
if just if we
if republicans get random people elected
because they're republicans
um and then they undo everything we
really are very screwed there's no
question about it it's just it may
it may just be narcissism that's a fair
point that's a fair point
obi-wan shinobi says caitlyn jenner is
the candace owens of trans people
i don't even care about the trans thing
you know it's just
i it you know uh it just i don't
understand
what the argument is um
okay now you know i
i i'm gonna do a ban i i'm seeing some
people deliberately misgendering caitlyn
jenner
in the um in the chat and i don't
i just don't like that i don't like that
so we're gonna drop band hammers on that
it's it's clearly not an
accident when you're saying he three
times in the same message
it's just not it's unbecoming it's
unbecoming
i do want to say thank you to cat quinn
cat quinn
oh yeah it was a mistake three times in
one message cat quinn is new member
number 22 today i really do appreciate
that
and uh thank you very much okay that's
everything i had for you guys today
um i am going to be back with more
streams more content and all sorts of
different things
i will at some point have a garden tour
for you and and so many different things
that are happening
um thank you for joining me if you're
watching on twitch make sure you're
following we are getting dangerously
close to our first hundred thousand
followers
and uh thanks to everybody watching on
youtube hit the subscribe button
do all of the things we all know we need
to do and i'll see you very soon